good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world so to help you on your journey
today's message is stop doing the wrong
things over to you Jordan B Peterson
[Music]
stop doing the things that you know are
wrong that you could stop doing right so
it's it's a fairly it's a fairly limited
attempt first of all we're not going to
say that you know what the good is or
what the truth is in any ultimate sense
but we will presume that there are
things that you're doing that for one
reason or another you know are not in
your best interests there's something
about them that you just know you should
stop there are kind of self-evident to
you other things you're gonna be
doubtful about you're not gonna know
which way is up and which way is down
but there are things that you're doing
that you know you shouldn't do now some
of those you won't stop doing for
whatever reason you don't have the
discipline or maybe there's a secondary
payoff or you don't believe it's
necessary or it's too much of a
sacrifice or you're angry or resentful
or or afraid who knows so forget about
those for now but there's another subset
that you could stop doing it might be
little thing well that's fine stop doing
it and see what happens and what will
happen is your vision will clear a
little bit and then something else will
pop up in your field of apprehension
that you will also know you should stop
doing and that you could stop doing
because you strengthened yourself a bit
by stopping doing the particulars stupid
thing that you were doing before that
just puts you together a little bit more
and you could do that repeatedly for for
an indefinite period of time and and you
know that doesn't necessarily mean that
you're going to ever be able to
formulate a clear and final picture of
what constitutes the truth and the good
but it does mean that you'll be able to
continually move away from what's
untruth and what's bad and you know well
that's not a bad start so I love the
messages stop doing the wrong things I
think it's vitally important the
question that becomes
and if we're limiting the things that
Jordan Peterson said are giving us some
kind of benefit then the ones that are
left at least in my opinion are the ones
that are giving you here the ones that
you are afraid of doing and so that you
don't go out and do it or the fear is
making you continue to do it and so for
me whenever there has been that kind of
fear or I'm doing something I'm not
doing something out of fear the solution
has always been to create a bigger fear
in the future and bring it back to today
it's not pretend like the fear doesn't
exist it's not pretend like that big
scary thing that you have to go and do
isn't real it's just I make the future
fear a lot bigger than the current fear
and so think about that thing that you
wish you can go and do think about that
project that you really want to start at
that person you really want to talk to
it that connection you really want to
make where the thing is that's kind of
9at you that you really really really
want to go out and do but you're not
because you're afraid think about your
life you know when you're 80 90 you know
200 years old and then look back on this
moment and the fact that you did not
take action on it has now led to a life
of decades of regret and I try to make
that as painful as possible as real and
painful as possible and bring that back
to right now so that I'm so afraid of
the future fear that I have to go and
take action and it doesn't mean it
always works out a lot of times it may
not work out you know you that you may
get rejected that deal may not work you
may lose money on something but for me
knowing is the key I can deal with
failure I can deal with something not
working out hopefully I don't make it a
huge colossal failure I could deal with
the failure but what I can't deal with
is not knowing and so two quick examples
I want to share with you one there was
this event called climber con in
California earlier this year and I hate
going to events where I'm not speaking I
don't like networking I don't like going
to conferences it's just not something
that I enjoy doing but it was for
youtubers with a hundred thousand plus
subscribers and some of the people that
I knew were going that I had kind of met
virtually I thought this might be
something that I should go to for once
an event looked interesting for me to go
to as a participant and not
as a speaker and I was hemming and
hawing like I should I go should I not
go and I delayed really long before
eventually buying my ticket and I just
came to the point where I'm gonna regret
not going I can deal with it not working
out I can deal with it being a total
bust
meeting nobody making no connections
wasting my time wasting my money to go I
could deal with that and if anything it
would prove my point that networking
events suck and I'm never gonna go to
another one again but I needed to know
and so I booked my ticket and I went and
it was okay you know I probably just got
my money's worth it wasn't amazing it
wasn't some huge success story but I
made some new connections I got to go
face-to-face with some people that I had
met before and I learned a couple of
things so it was net a little bit
positive right another example when I
was putting what my book I worked with a
number of different people to help me
promote a different agencies different
different connections and there was one
who had a had a reputation that looked
really interesting and gave me a
proposal and I was a little skeptical of
doing it but again I felt like if I
didn't say yes I would regret it and so
I said yes and to be honest it didn't
really work out you know I paid a lot of
money and I didn't get I didn't get the
result I didn't get my money's worth at
all I didn't get zero value but I didn't
get the value that I I felt I had paid
for but it's okay
like it's a lesson learned and I'm not
gonna live the next 90 years with regret
that I didn't say yes and you're
wondering what if what if what if what
if what if you know there's been other
times where has worked out insanely well
when I worked with my agent for the
first time I almost didn't say yes I was
on the fence and I just felt like I
might regret it and it worked out really
really really well I got a lot better on
camera or my youtube channel started to
explode I got a book deal and other
opportunities and so don't be so
attached to the outcome of it working or
not working right like it has to work or
was a huge failure for me it's much more
if there's something that I ever feel
like I might regret and you're just
delaying and delaying
Delaine eventually that Windows gonna
close you're gonna miss your opportunity
and so make that future fear so big
bring it back to today it's I'm gonna
I'm gonna regret this for the next 90
years of my life I need to know you
could deal with it not working out you
could deal with failure you could deal
with the rejection but what you can't
deal with is not knowing so the question
of the day I'm curious what is that
thing that's not at you that you really
want to try you really want to test
really want to go out and do but you're
afraid what is that thing for you right
now
in your business in your life leave it
down in the comments below really
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout out to win winters women
thank you so much for picking up a cup
of my book your one word I really
appreciate the support and I hope you
enjoyed the room so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you guys again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
vinspresso
[Music]
the sound grows what you focus on grows
if you focus on problems problems of
multiply if you focus on opportunities
opportunities will multiply you have to
choose what you're gonna spend your time
on see everyday hearing they're getting
better or worse you don't stay the same
in life people don't stay the same
they're either getting better or they're
worse you're not a human being you're a
human becoming okay every day you are
changing your life and you are every day
becoming your current most dominant
thought not what you say you're thinking
about not what you tell other people
you're doing
you are becoming what you're thinking
Napoleon Hill said thoughts are things
electrode you'll synapses between nerve
endings thoughts are visions
what are you allowing to be in your
brain what are you focusing on what are
you spending your time oh who influences
you a human being does not become who he
is because of his desire he becomes who
he is because of his competence so in
some enhancing your competence you just
enhancing your desire which will be just
a horrible burden to carry all the time
you just focus on enhancing the
competence of who this is rather than
enhancing your desire I am going to
become a world champion everybody wants
to become one they're not going to
become one isn't it everybody wants to
be successful they will not be a success
unless you do the right things success
will not happen to you can I tell you a
joke 45 minutes you got to be serious we
can
let me tell you on a certain day a man
fell into a septic tank the right up
till here in felt he desperately tried
to come out he could not then he started
screaming fire fire neighbors heard this
call the fire brigade five firemen came
rushing they looked all over the place
no fire then they found this man they
pulled him out and then they asked why
were you screaming fire where is the
fire the man retorted if I said [ __ ]
[ __ ] would you come
we were to do the right things otherwise
the right things will not happen to you
just because you have a big desire
you're not going to get there you got to
do the right things